dans mon jardin il y a aussi des tulipes
cette fleur est originaire d'iran et
d'afghanistan
au début du 16e siècle elle ne pousse
que dans les jardins du sultan soliman
le magnifique
à istanbul une fois posées sur leur tête
le bandeau des dignitaires ottoman
ressemblait tellement à cette fleur qui
en prit le nom du liban qui va donner
curbans bien qu'il ne le fait jamais et
qu'il les garde pour lui le sultan
philippe a redonné un bulbe un botaniste
des pays bas qui le multiple amsterdam
cette fleur si rare prend beaucoup de
valeur un bulbe pouvait valoir le prix
d'une maison
vous imaginez la fortune aller à demain
et surtout n'oubliez pas nous sommes
tous confinés
mais on reste en lien si vous avez aimé
cette capsule 2d confiné n'hésitez pas à
laisser un pouce bleus gens réalisent
une nouvelle chaque jour alors pour ne
pas les rater abonnez-vous et activer la
cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain